هل يعتقد أي شخص في هذه الغرفة
بخلاف الحكومة والجنود في أي مكان آخر
أن المستوطنات غير القانونية لا
تحدث والتي هي عمليات إخلاء قسري ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني ولكن
الدولة الإسرائيلية لا تحدث
أن عمليات الهدم لا تحدث
وأن عمليات الاعتقال والتعذيب والقتل غير المشروع
كما يتضح من  التقرير
لا أعتقد أننا نفعل ذلك ، أعتقد أن
حكومة جورجيا تقبل أن هذه الأشياء
تحدث ويتم
إلحاقها بالشعب الفلسطيني من قبل
دولة إسرائيل ، لكننا مع ذلك نقيد أنفسنا في صياغة
العبارات ،
فهذا لا يتعلق بالعبارات ولا يتعلق بما إذا كان أو
ليست جائزة معينة مفيدة ،
إنها مسألة قانونية
، إن اللورد الدولي واضح أن
النظام الاجتماعي للهيمنة
والقمع من قبل مجموعة عرقية على
أخرى يشكل جريمة
الفصل العنصري ضد الإنسانية
إذا أدركنا أن
أنظمة القمع هذه تحدث ،
فهذا يتجاوز  إهانة أننا نتجادل
حول
العبارات
إذا كنا نعتقد أن العقوبات متعارضة
ضد الاتحاد الروسي
بسبب غزوه البشع والإرهاب الذي
يعاني منه شعب أوكرانيا
هو أمر مشروع لأننا تحركنا بسرعة
وبسرعة كما ينبغي أن يكون لدينا
الفرق
لماذا كنا بطيئين للغاية في التصرف لا
يوجد مبرر